which is they're hot right now there is
a pagan Academy in New York City where
they are training Wiccans and witches
being a little glib about this but it's
a it's a real thing that actually
probably is legitimate as any other
religion out there and as someone that's
trained in the Jedi arts I really
shouldn't be making fun of this um okay
so it was established the Wiccan family
Temple Academy of pagan studies was
established in 2007 and you know they're
teaching Wiccan studies so this of
course it lends itself to a lot of jokes
and are they flying around on brooms and
is it like Hogwarts Academy and all that
but do you think just these sort of
offshoot random things are as legit as
the big three religions that we talk
about all the time I would say no not
because of the religion itself I would
say so I went to their website and their
main font is Comic Sans so so that's
what I would say I don't think they're
legit based on that reason I don't go to
restaurants if they have Comic Sans and
yeah I used to like Comic Sans and then
it became the joke of the fun right
satisfied it's the sad it's just like oh
I want to be creative but I'm not really
I want to be funny or joke your stand
out the comic cent okay so here's the
thing yes I feel like most girls not all
girls and people are gonna be in the
comment section like you're crazy
I was never Wiccan I like a lot of girls
go through a phase where you decide to
explore witchcraft and be wicked for me
it happened twice one time it was like
in junior high and we were like let's
probably does the craft or something
like that exactly you're like let's be
dark and evil and we're dark it's almost
like you're weird goth but you think
you're Wiccan and then another period in
college where they're all these like you
know indie bookstores that had a lot of
Wiccan books and I would read them and
and I was like this is kind of cool it's
kind of like nature and the elements and
it makes sense and it seems like a
religion that's less you know has a
stranglehold on what you do and word is
kind of harm no one and do what you will
I think is the Wiccan credo I think if
you have to sit in a room and stand up
sit down stand up sit down the idea of
harm to and do what you will isn't
harming anyone that's their credo by
nature is that you don't harm other
people and it's kind of interesting so
I'll say I think a lot of people do go
girls in particular I don't know but
go through a wicking exploration period
when you're a teenager right did you
ever do anything did you try to concoct
day did you put lizards I in addition
Newt or whatever was going on but they
do have certain I think you're
interested in it especially when we were
young when I was in junior high do that
phase we're like let's cast spells to
make this boy like God but you're so
innocent not you know were like Oh Bobby
he's so cute on the football team if we
all sit here and it was almost like a
seance with a Ouija board we're like
make them like us um that's really
creepy it's way more creepier than I
thought would come out yeah but I think
you know you go through these different
phases where you explore different
things there's nothing wrong with this
academy existing it's obviously I mean
it's just like there's a lot of
religions that make ton of money like
Scientology that people think are an
offshoot it's a huge religion um and
also just even Catholicism and the
Anglican Church was a spinoff of that so
there's different spin-offs of all
different sorts of religions and just
accepted exists and people want to be
which is cool yet is is also part of it
though that the other three the big
three religions we are so inundated with
their images like if you really when you
watch you know they get a new pope and
it's so over-the-top and crazy and the
outfits and the hat I mean the whole
thing so freakin gay an old fire and the
smoke in the hole and it's so bonkers
and yet when I read this so the High
Priestess star Raven Hawk guessing
that's not her given name uh she told
The Times if people really knew what we
are about they would know that studying
to become a good witch is no different
than studying to become a good Catholic
and I bet that probably is true so maybe
none of its that great how about that
you know I could say yeah all the
religions yeah like they're in a witch's
hat and the other ones in a big pointy
hat I mean what's the different what
they all have hats I know I don't
support anything I can't prove so
therefore all religions own all religion
to me is I think it's fun to have and
it's fun to have tradition but I believe
in the universe yeah because you believe
we're here right now that's that's
pretty much what I I don't know
I can prove it you're not sure yeah yeah
I believe we're here right now do you
think we're here right I hope so yeah I
mean if we're not here gonna get real
weird yeah if we're not here right now
then where are we
that would be we're in that weird cool
down plant and like really being
incubated there and no okay so the
wicked back to wick getting back to
whatever I understand I guess maybe your
question is like are people paying money
to go to a church that doesn't exist or
being offered you know skills in
witchcraft and is this really be a
that's more Bunker like really is there
anyone that's more bonkers like we all
seem to think that Scientology maybe is
more bonkers than this one because
they're putting Tom Cruise in the steam
room with a bunch of guys or whatever
offensive I think all religions are
Anjali and bonkers to me or equally as
interesting or connive or could have
equal meaning to certain people so you
know I don't want to crap on people's
religions or support them because for me
it's kind of all the same yeah I just
feel like you know every Wiccan that's
the same thing as being Catholic to me
they're all the same like you know
choose what you will and if you that
makes you feel better to believe in it
great and if not you know be a thinking
person and maybe think things through
and don't just blindly follow religion
and be a thinking person that's pretty
that's pretty do you guys think some of
this though has to do with movies
because I saw a study that in England
that like the fifth highest religion the
fifth highest ranked religion really is
Jedi I mean people in the census put
down Jedi and then if you think about
the witch thing I mean Harry Potter is
pretty popular but more this stuff pops
up in pop culture like people are gonna
start believing in really sort of more
bonkers things like unicorns like a
unicorn lover yes I a I'm gonna make
them come to life that's our thing
instead of saying I believe in the
universe you're supposed to say I
believe in unicorn
yeah community yeah yeah all right well
on that note we've wrapped this whole
thing up so Sean I'm going to let you
tell people about your unicorns first
talk to camp manager to get ready for a
new book called unicorns on computer
paper coming out TBD and follow me at
Sean Hollenbach on Twitter excellent
Jenn hi i am jim hoffman who wishes I
was on Google but since I'm not you can
follow me on Twitter at Jenn - which is
je n an HOF FMA and not the photographer
who people think is me on there yeah
forget about that lady and i'm dave
rubin you can follow me on twitter at
reuben report i hope you're doing that
already and just a little shout out to
all you NSA guys out there we did what
you're doing and to all you Wiccans and
what else did we cover today all us
james franco good luck with that yeah
all right thanks guys we'll see you next
week